[Music]
oh good
you
as mayor of the universe I would see sea
cuckoo blocks and the biggest level of
Christmas and all gasping the love of
this holiday is unrivaled by any way for
this award
I'm very flattered by it it's so
wonderful to know that no one in the
entire solar system anywhere loved
Christmas
as much as I contest
well it sounds like a much better being
broken and the speed of power dishwater
and every conceivable ozone layer being
shattered
I win when life gives you lemons you say
fuck lemons with Mike written it's the
greatest time of a year and we're once
again going to celebrate all the
merriment it has to offer
let's know the hot chocolate whatever
the hell I'm looking at here Christmas
has everything and in this part of
celebrating the holidays we also have to
look at the weirdest parts of it no Matt
Patrick Stewart wearing a singing elf
hat you can watch that later I'm of
course talking about Inspector Gadget
saves Christmas
it's a weird list of people who have
saved Christmas isn't it
Ernest berenstain bears the glow friends
Elmo Mader from cars Diego the brass
babies if get mental ward patients be
with the cat it kind of feels like
anyone can save Christmas it's not
particularly hard so why not throw
Inspector Gadget into the mix based on
the hey kid show about a bumbling
inspector as ignore prodigy of a nice
the special aired in December of 1992
just six years before its cinematic
follow-up so awaiting an apology tour no
I gotta get out of here man was
nominated for an Oscar the great thing
about this special is it's pretty much
exactly what you think is going to be
the first few images that pop in your
head when you hear this title is 100%
what it consists of it's ridiculous in
the way the only Inspector Gadget can
provide so let's go go gadget dollar
store attention
this is Inspector Gadget saves Christmas
we start off outside the incredibly well
advertised Santa's workshop you know
you're sending mixed signals with a
wooden sign yet electric muttering I'll
just put this on there while you're at
it
Santa wakes up his workers with his
synthesized trumpet playing a man of
many random talents and he wakes them up
again by singing because apparently the
trumpet did nothing
[Music]
like in Chinese - I've been bad if I say
there ever been sighted Chinese - kids
and watch everything has its we're drunk
over there - up and down good inside
we're skid even more grim the pretty you
listen to them is what I can think of
are the pretty unforgiving set up
imagine these words being spoken instead
of some yeah die another day making toy
presenter isn't work
it's play players work working play
selector we realize names a shanghaied
the Keebler elves or some sort of
illegal cloning ring arm a melon dr.
claw enters the picture
yes this is really happening
dr. claw is dressing up like Santa I am
not prepared for this kind of silly
maybe if I watch this okay okay let's
try it again I have so many questions
first of all Wow who knew dr. claw was
so short I guess sitting down so let's
just give you the shin Lake of Hank Hill
father second his arms seem to have
gotten scrawny don't you think does he
eat carbs third what exactly is this
scheme again I don't eat all the ruined
Christmas myself and the world plays
like that's a weird plan buddy what do
you care if you ruin Christmas or even
if Santa gets blamed your focus used to
be robberies
terrorism obtaining power what does
making Santa look lazy accomplish
Santa's name will be slashed reputation
will be ruined and I will have the honor
of having done back look at you kept
losing to an eight-year-old your
criminal plan center around what
eight-year-old care about your making
this guy look rebel now how dare you so
dr. claw uses his mind-controlling hat
on the elves because this is our reality
for the next half hour and operate the
hook crane to lift Santa get me down
Chuck Skellington I told you I'm done
with this shit
stop me now first as soon as I figure
out how to stop us no from looking like
streams of urine seriously are bunch of
snowmen taking a piss up there first we
see Inspector Gadget at his house as mad
agents try to get it look at this they
can't even get the original Inspector
Gadget theme song oh come on the theme
song was like half a show
what's big ships are playing with
literally making this up as we go the
court failed to stop him most likely
because of his pops dreams portal gun
how she as Inspector Gadget it's given
his next assignment from the chief once
again undercover but where's the real
Santa he could be in trouble here your
assignment will explain weighted sheep
it sounding like Clint Eastwood after a
million marbles I know now get off the
phone do you feel jelly Punk suspicious
activity at North Pole suggest Mad Black
by dr. kloor against the real Santa
Claus you know the thought occurs to me
that were rather Klaus centric have we
ever thought about going after Isis drug
lord some people who make the Madea
movies I'll get to the bottom of this
you know this has happened so much it's
actually starting to feel good so gadget
being the caring uncle that he is of
course brings his niece Penny along who
static line is down ha ha that's great
ha brain is clearly voiced by a
different actress but come on how could
you replace crease summer it seems like
a voice acting giant she was perfect for
penny gadget how dare they get a little
kid to voice the little kid what's wrong
with you well maybe her acting so good
it's a fitting replacement this must be
what dr. claw had Santa's real toys okay
well maybe she's popular from the other
thing she's been in like the NIA
Quigley's horror workout I have no idea
why they chose this person Oh
look uncle gadget Santa's Village it's a
Christmas dream come true if only we
could fix the reception gadget falls in
the snow but he quickly gets out with a
bit of comedy if you get my drift I
invented the laser watch the femurs
beneath me so we saw easily dr. claw
snuck in I would have they beefed up
security at all do they even lock their
doors our Yoo Lian afraid old valve
might be kidnapped by Willy Wonka when
you're not looking
gadget of course goes to greet who he
thinks is Santa ah gadget you're always
welcome at the North Pole
why Santa you're sounding charmingly
satanic today I she such a silly idea
that the notorious toxic law has
infiltrated the North Pole oh okay I'm
just calling it right here I think dr.
Claus should be our new Santa dr. Santa
Clau hearing him say ho ho ho is my
everything Christmas would be amazing if
you would Santa sis imagine Jim greeting
kids at the mall I was going and go to
the trip to my fire pit
where do you want oh fuck get a kitten I
hate getting Kindle even boy how dare
you dr. claw what's up I can't help but
notice all the children you're torturing
in horrific way it's not my fault that
the plan is dead dr. claw just exactly
what are you a doctor of pediatrics I
have a hard time believing that sir I
have a hard time believing your face now
that is not called Okazaki appendage
when would they realize any one of these
kid could invent a computer book and
ruin all our schemes and just add of my
time
you
[Music]
so funny starts to put together that
something might be up high I'll bet you
some great Santa stories mr. elf
interesting sound effect show did he
have flashbacks when he was on the ship
from alien nice talking to ya hear
something weird going on here brain yeah
there's something weird about these
enchanted Oh magical talking dog of
course penny once again has to save the
day well can't it just makes things
worried cat in which she got the credit
she deserves I mean I know it's good to
be humble and everything but her picture
would be placed above ginger homers by
this point the brain would get a little
pissed off seeing how he's always the
one who has to save gadget while she
calmly moves around
why does he always get the short end of
the stick Henry you fell uncle gadget
I'm going to find out what's going on
[Music]
forget it inspects the factory as well
as the toys or other things about it on
the first phase inspection good trapper
show to me I'm not fine with gadget
training wheel with vocal cords have one
bar with up with the audio how the hell
did his voice go from this go go gadget
magnifying glass on the first phase
inspection good Shabbes show to me yeah
well I think he literally pull this in
was he just sitting at his home like I
don't want to come down to the studio
I'm too busy seeing who played it with
me I'll just record it to my garage I
hear the acoustics there are amazing
would you believe semi amazing one of
this phase inspection good Santa Show
give me a song that goes on too long
because we need some filler and it's
public domain so we don't have to pay
for it
how's Inspector Gadget gadget is tossing
to the same holding cell as Santa as
wait a minute
I know that's worth Santa's being held
it's like a special dungeon so he can't
get out of everything but why does Santa
have one of those in the first place
this workshop is getting creepier and
creepier
maybe dr. Klaus Marmot hero that we gave
him credit for
go go gadget interrogation device ah
forget about ever right idea this time
okay that's a little weird
yeah you expect me to believe that so
why do I get a feeling this is going to
be a sequel to the movie pickles there a
Santa getting particles don't tell me if
there is so far you know sales are
shaped like a bowl full of jelly
okay this special needs an r-rating cuz
I swear he said shit like a bowl full of
jelly you know sales are shaped like a
bowl full of jelly
well Metamucil cookies I left out every
year always did the trick your eyes
don't twinkle your nipples are merry as
this ruddy Patriot winning pool anyone
well this is horrific is this what
you're expecting kids watching your
childhood icon get the shit beat out of
them by law enforcement
falala get is not really doing what
saving Christmas is he he's more
Halloween Christmas Merry Christmas
filthy animal
meanwhile penny has to figure out what's
going on with a little convention as
possible whoo he's in a jail cell
that's bad motherfucker you did it kid
he's down the real Santa Claus that's
good oh they're turning one of the
greatest child heroes into a leapfrog
preschool game can you spot what's good
and bad that's good dad
and that's good that's bad I'll go
gadget put a dog collar on Sandra okay
this is getting a little weird for me
particularly in the dungeon and the
effing elves were one thing but I can't
show it's been forget it escapes and
helps claw load up his leg okay are you
sure can't just let them do in here but
haven't you forgotten dunderhead
blitzkrieg and the other reindeer I'll
teach you everything myself you know I
really should fire my strategy that
visits the person I'm losing to all
these years submarine and Penny try to
get the elves back to their normal self
especially after they've mastered
teleportation okay it's gotta just
travelling back in time and randomly
beaming people what they find the
control and return them to their usual
swearing cells tingle down up and down
you are all getting soaked for dinner a
claw isn't done yet
oh come on in his place cooler
what can't he be Sansa you can on your
frame we'd like to eat when identities
again toys you can't stop me from
ruining Christmas Wow for the first time
ever make it actually listen to what I
said out loud I'm a buffoon I just
quoted a man who tortured me for hours
insanity 1 my mental health 0 the
reindeers antlers somehow dig through an
iceberg of solid mass steroid oats and
think dr. Klaus plan into the ocean
oh look at the blank stares on those
else they've seen things things they can
never explain nor wish to understand
just move on
never look back I don't know why you do
Helicon from what you saved Christmas
for the children of the world now time
for that chief Christmas awaits but I've
been waiting for hours somehow and this
guy it's like the Bermuda Triangle of
air pockets so Fanta get this leg going
and even invites get it to come along
with it right we're high enough let's
awesome Wow that's what the climb so
that was like forget it save Christmas
it's pretty much exactly what you'd
expect from it it's silly ridiculous and
doesn't make a lick of sense apart on
what your specs when you watch Inspector
Gadget if you hear the title Inspector
Gadget saves Christmas and you have any
interest in it whatsoever it's probably
going to give you what you're looking
for gadget acting like a dummy dr. claw
trying to take over the North Pole brain
getting hurt in the process the only
thing that always sucks like I said
before is any always getting the ship I
hate that she's the one doing all the
hard work she should get the credit it's
not fair I tell you it's not fair
can we just one day see penny get
exactly what she deserves
what is that one greetings people of the
world for years you've been under the
assumption that my uncle Inspector
Gadget was a respected detective with a
metro city brief voice Vikram are just a
cunning ruse did you really think that a
bumbling stick with the voice of John
Adams can accomplish super impossible
feat and still be human
for God's sake hear the fucking
helicopter and you can
and yet nobody questioned where the hell
is bringing I created the gadget 9000
prototype and he's done as himself or
and why would I created artificial life
I don't anything on an unsuspecting
world's your chances stealth bombers are
no match for the Hellfire and the vet
and Legionella difficult first the
controversy and the shadows is that in
confidence
shit got all the credits I can press the
entire enter that into my textbook tada
canine how to simulate human speech and
created the Ocelot before Steve Jobs out
of his mother's basement give me a
better ten years I would created a
fucking matrix
complete with the Keanu Reeves that can
actually ask you've got the real enemy
was not but they were merely a
distraction as long as gadget and cloth
on the police were always occupied for
you see I was spoiling that plan so that
when the time came I control of your
government your thermonuclear warhead
your lives
I am penny mother of gadget breaker of
brains I will take that be honor that
was stolen from me and destroy those who
stand in my way this is a great uncle
gadget
whoa
any fetus that make peace
is our yeah but you're supposed to just
say oh I don't like that uncle gadget
okay
[Music]
you
that's bad
hey guys Doug Walker here doing the
charity shout out this week we are doing
the Midwest Food Bank this charity works
to stop hunger and poverty by gathering
and distributing food donations to over
900 nonprofit local organizations and
disaster site based on the data from
Charity Navigator the firm has achieved
the highest rating for fiscal
responsibility and excellence for six
consecutive years for fiscal 2014 of the
63 point 221 million dollars raised
ninety nine point thirty percent went
directly towards delivering its services
and only twenty fifty percent went
towards administrative expenses that's
amazing if you look at their site or
their YouTube page you can see for
yourself all the great work that they do
they work so hard in making sure that
people this holiday season don't go
hungry there's so many people that need
food in the world and these are the
people that make it possible that they
don't go to bed starving it's a
wonderful organization and definitely
deserves your attention this Christmas
when so many people are in the
charitable mood definitely keep this one
open your heart
[Music]